إنها مزعجة ذات أرجل طويلة، وفي كثير من
الأحيان لا تعرف حتى بوجودها، لقد كان
البشر في حالة حرب مع البعوض
حرفيًا، كما تعلم منذ آلاف السنين،
وهذه الحشرات أكثر من مجرد مصدر
إزعاج كل عام، حيث
يمكن للأمراض التي يمكن أن ينقلها البعوض والنواقل الأخرى  يتسبب الانتشار في وفاة أكثر
من
700000 شخص في جميع أنحاء العالم، وفي الصيف
يخرجون بكامل قوتهم مما يوفر
بيئة رائعة حقًا للبعوض
للخروج والتجول
والاستمتاع بصيدهم اليومي للبشر.
يعمل كونور ماكمينامين مع
معهد أبحاث ودراسات الملاريا بجامعة جونز هوبكنز.
يقول إن انجذاب البعوض للبشر، على الرغم من أن الحشرات صغيرة الحجم، إلا
أنها تتمتع بحاسة شم قوية
ويمكنها تتبع التوقيعات الكيميائية التي
ينبعثها جسم الإنسان من خلال أنفاسنا ورائحة الجلد، إلا أن
بعض الناس أكثر جاذبية
للبعوض من غيرهم، ونحن
نعتقد أن  جزء كبير من السبب في
ذلك هو الطريقة التي نشم بها
نوعين مختلفين من البعوض،
يقول مكمينامين إن أفضل طريقة للاستعداد ضد
البعوض هي الاستعداد في
منزلك، واستخدام شاشات النوافذ وتكييف الهواء
والمراوح لجعل البيئة أقل
جاذبية في حديقتك  قم بإزالة
المياه الراكدة وإزالة الحطام حيث
قد يتجمع البعوض ويتكاثر ويحمي
جسمك من خلال تغطية الأكمام والسراويل الطويلة
أو استخدم طارد الحشرات المسجل لدى وكالة حماية البيئة (EPA)
والذي يحتوي على
مكونات نشطة مثل
بيكاتين التمر IR 3535، وهو
مكونات صناعية رائعة حقًا في Waterway
البعوض ل  دقيقة صحية أنا آندي
جيثر